Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich
and this is Radiolab,
the podcast Jad Abumrad who's
normally at my side is still at home,
eking out the very end of his paternity
leave with his brand new baby.
So I've been very careful
not to disturb him,
which means though I do have to
find somebody else to fight with.
And I did manage to get into a nice
little tussle with Richard Dawkins, uh,
one of the great defenders
of Charles Darwin.
He's the Charles Simoni professor of
public understanding of science at Oxford.
He also comes from a long
line of Combative Englishman,
including a guy who tried to burn down
an Ivy League college in the United
States. In fact,
why don't we begin with a
little biographical sketch
of Richard Dawkins that I
used to introduce him to an audience
at the 92nd street y in New York City.
And then we'll get onto the discussion.
I told them the Dawkins is Greek, Greek,
Greek. Great, great, great,
great, great, great grandfather.
Going back to the 17 hundreds
was the major commander of the British
forces who fought George Washington here
in the American revolution. And it was
Richard Doxins Dawkins' his great, great,
great, great, great,
great. Whatever. Sure.
Henry Clinton who hired Benedict
Arnold to be the British spy who almost
captured west point, which is Washington
stronghold. Didn't do it though,
cause they cut the spies and so forth.
It was Dawkins. Great, great, great,
great, great,
great grandfather who commanded the
British occupation forces here in New York
City in 1777 78 it was his Greek,
Greek, Greek, a Greek big man,
father who authorized rating parties
on a variety of seashore communities.
If you live in them, please hold
your fire egg harbor in New Jersey,
attacked by his great, great
grandfather, new Bedford, Massachusetts,
a part of Martha's vineyard called
Vineyard Haven. Most insidiously,
he okayed and attack on new haven,
Connecticut with the plan to burn
down Gail College. Fortunately,
his forces as they often were,
were repulsed. Ultimately,
Sir Henry Clinton lost
the war and went home.
But sir, Henry's great, great, great,
great grand son Richard Dawkins has been
back to America over and over and over
again to do battle with more modern
Americans when he calls the most
scientifically illiterate
populace outside the third world.
So Richard Dawkins does not mince words.
And when we began our conversation,
which was about evolution
in Charles Darwin,
he opened with a surprisingly
forceful statement.
As an academic scientist,
I am a passionate Darwinian
believing that natural selection is,
if not the only driving
force in evolution,
certainly the only known force capable
of producing the illusion of purpose,
which so strikes all who
contemplate nature bopped at
the same time as I support
Darwinism as a scientist,
I am a passionate anti Darwinian when
it comes to politics and how we should
conduct our human affairs.
So He's, he's given us something of
a riddle. I mean, he loves Darwin,
but he also loads the styling.
And then for extra spice,
he wants you to know that anybody
who thinks there's a purpose,
a reason why we live and look and
behave the way we do is under a terrible
illusion. There is no purpose to our
existence. No reason why we're here.
That's basic. Darwin, he's
has, sorry, I thought, okay,
I'll let's do the purpose
thing first. This the Darwin's theory
I think does a very good job on,
because it can tell you why something is
shaped the way it is or as the color it
is or does the function is
because, because, because,
but if you step back and you ask the
bigger question, what's it all for?
This happens involves your daughter.
Your daughter is driving around with
you and you're looking, she sees us.
She's six years old. She sees a, a
field of flowers. You say to her, well,
what do you think they're
for? She says, well,
to make the world pretty and to help
bees make honey for us, you think, well,
I was sorry to tell him
that this wasn't true.
And I explained to her that the
flowers are not there to make the world
beautiful and they are not there
to delight bees or anything else.
They're in the world to copy
their DNA. So a six year old.
Yeah.
But essentially what you're doing
there is furious addressing.
You're opening the eye notion to her
that the world is a purposeless in
different machine where the meaning of
things is not clear if it exists at all.
You found that, I think kind of
brave to say to your daughter, look,
step by step into the wind
of exciting, exciting.
I mean it's a far more exciting view
of LAUSD to understand what they're,
what they're really doing
and, and a six year old,
she had no problem understanding
that. I explained it to her,
but,
but to come to your, what,
what's it for question it,
it's a piece of massive
presumption to think that the,
what is for question
deserves an answer. There's,
there's no reason at all why
something should have a fall about it.
If I said to you, what is the Sun
for? Or what is Mount Everest for,
you would say then because
silly it's not, it's not the,
it's not inappropriate question,
but because it's flowers, um, you,
you sort of feel that there ought to
be or what is it for question? No,
actually I think it's a harder question
than that. I think human beings,
I think most human beings have some deep
impulse to explain their being here to
wonder about the origins of here and
the destiny of them and here and that
question,
the meaning of it all is not
a silly question. It's not,
that's not a silly question and it
has a perfectly good answer. Uh,
which is not an answer to be
couched in the language of purpose.
It's an answer to be couched in the
language of scientific causation.
What brought us all to
be here? What is the,
the explanation for our existence that
has a perfectly good scientific answer.
Uh,
and you go back in evolutionary time to
the origin of life and then you go back
before the origin of life
to the origin of the world,
the origin of the solar system, the
origin of the universe, and that,
that it becomes deeply mysterious.
Needless to say, it's not,
it's not a question I could
even begin to answer. And I,
I don't think that at the
present stage physics can either,
but to the extent that
there's going to be an answer,
it's going to come from science and that
is a deeply satisfying kind of answer
to the question, why are we here?
We already have in principle the answer
to that question and it is not an answer
of the form. We are here in
order to achieve some purpose.
It's an answer of the form we are here
because something happened which led to
something else that happened, which led
to something else that happened. Uh, um,
are you, uh, let me just
ask you the harder question.
Is this hard looking in this telling
your six year old, this leads to,
this leads to this, this kind of reduction
is way of thinking about everything.
Does that seem to you to be less
than joyously imaginative? No, I,
I know, um, I think that's
kind of super romantic, um, to,
to actually understand that flowers, uh,
devices, beautiful devices,
elegant devices which are shaped precisely
to attract insects and hummingbirds,
uh,
and bats to take pollen
from one to another.
That is such a mind blowing
thought compared to the
team sort of washed out view
that flowers are just sort of
nice things to have around.
Um,
don't encourage him. So I lost that round,
at least with the New York audience.
And I know there are a lot of you
listening who kind of agree with those New
Yorkers that, you know, this is,
this is the name of the game. If, if,
if you know the details of the glorious,
beautiful details, that's enough.
If you've been listening to
this podcast long enough,
you know that for some of us it's
not quite enough. But anyway,
um, I then asked about the second
proposition. I asked him, well,
what does it mean when you say
that you're a passionate Darwinian?
And at the same time a
passionate NT Darwinian
as an academic scientist,
I believe that Darwinism not only is
the true explanation for why evolution
happened in particular, why evolution
led to the spectacularly elegant,
beautiful,
complicated and apparently
designed structures that we see.
It's therefore a theory of immense
elegance, of immense power,
of immense scientific beauty.
But if you try to apply the lesson of
Darwinism as the social Darwinists did to
human society,
then you end up with a kind of
super Thatcherism you end up with,
or it, or even Hitler,
for example, he said there
are people who love die.
When he mentioned the
science fiction writer, wells
wells assume that survival of the fittest
means that only the fittest and the
best creatures get to survive.
But Darwin didn't say that.
He didn't use the phrase survival
of the fittest and his book.
And he didn't ever say that evolution
is there to make better and better
creatures. As you just heard Richard
Dawkins say, evolution isn't for anything.
But when hg wells red dye,
when he decided Darwin was teaching us
to get rid of our less fit brothers and
sisters,
the new republic where wells outlines
his Darwinian utopia contained some blood
chilling lines so unpleasant that I
find it hard to read them aloud perhaps.
I mean, it's such a striking thing
I bring myself to. It's pretty bad.
I'm sorry, I'm having trouble if
I [inaudible]. Here we are. Um,
and how will the new republic
treat the inferior races?
How will it deal with the
black, the Yellow Man, the Jew,
those swarms of black and brown and
dirty white and yellow people who do not
come into the new needs
of efficiency? Well,
the world is a world and not a charitable
institution and I take it they will
have to go. And the ethical system
of these men, of the new republic,
the ethical system which will dominate
the world state will be shaped primarily
to favor the procreation of what is
fine and efficient and beautiful in
humanity, beautiful and strong
bodies, clear and powerful minds.
And the method that
nature has followed here,
the two in the shaping of the world
whereby weakness was prevented from
propagating weakness is death.
The man of the new republic will have an
ideal that will make the killing worth
the while.
That was hg wells in something like 1,902,
I forget exactly when it
was published, but, um,
I understand this,
you mean your notion about
Auntie Darwinian is that
in our brains we have these
tendencies to make war against people
who are not like us to assign different
roles to men and women to perhaps
favor our biological children over his
stepchildren.
And in our brains we have the other
places where we might make war against the
tendencies that we've
in here against that.
Um, I think that's right. I mean, you
put the dilemma rather well that, um,
here we do have our evolved tendencies
which have these unpleasant features and
it must be in some sense elsewhere in our
brain that we have the desire to fight
them.
And I think it comes after
a long period of education.
Uh,
we have moved away from the
mores of our wild ancestors and,
uh, thank goodness we have,
I'm not quite sure it's a very difficult
historical process to wonder quite how
that's happened, but it very clearly has,
I mean like contraception in itself
is good enough evidence that, um,
that we do go against
Darwinian principles. Um,
so it can be done.
And the fact that most of us spend most
of our lives striving for purposes,
striving for goals which have nothing to
do with propagating ourself as genes is
further evidence that it can be done. So
notion then is that we are, we live
in a world carved by these forces,
but our job in part is to
recognize the good from the bed,
choose and fight for the good.
Well, as we understand it, this is
my suggestion. I mean,
you obviously that's a matter of
taste whether you want to do that,
but most people who live in, in civilized
society do, do want to do that. And,
uh, I would,
I would like to live in the sort of
society which is not run on Darwinian
principles while fully acknowledging that
the brains and bodies that we possess
were put there by Darwinian
principles in the first place. Yeah.
You mentioned in the reading,
there's something about this
unique gift of foresight.
Now as I understand how how normal
evolution works is you're in a particular
place, a specific environment.
It gets cold say and you got a few
more feathers than the other bird.
So you have that advantage of
having a few more feathers.
So he should be shivers, shivers and
dies and you go out and have a baby.
Now cause I this idea,
whoever is [inaudible] it's based
in time in this moment. Yeah.
Now you said something about how human
beings have the unique gift of foresight.
How does that, well, the, the,
the example you [inaudible]
give of the bird with the most feathers
surviving and laying the most eggs,
that's exactly how it would work.
And there is no foresight there,
but human beings can
look ahead and say, well,
in a few decades time it's going
to get cold as an ice age forecast.
So let's develop some new
technology that will coach.
We could do, Oh yes. Um, that,
that's foresight and
foresight has literally never
happened before in the whole
history of life. Yeah.
But if people with this foresight
decide, okay, let's breed a,
a set of flying horses so that we can
leave the cold places and gallop off to
the warm places at that point. Is
Evolution as you understand it over they,
in other words,
does that new ingredient adding
foresight to the mix take away one of the
essential bits of this that
somehow it happens without a plan.
Now there was a plan. Yeah. Um, I presume,
I don't need to say to this sophisticated
audience that you're an example of
that making horses that flies
a hypothetical and, and um, um,
well I have a horse that flies in the
second row, but he's quiet at the moment.
Um, yes. Um, it,
it does suggest that theoretically in
future centuries perhaps evolution could
take an entirely new human guided term
and you really could plan for the future
of evolution. Well, let me ask you
the tougher question. If you know,
and I know that we as a group,
as a species are capable of
creating flying horses or whatever,
does that then take us above all the
other animals and above all the other
plants and give us back our special
place that Darwin sort of made thought
tumbled us from? Yes.
I think that there are lots
of big differences between
humans and other species
and lots of big differences between
each species and each other species,
but humans are especially
differently different.
And one of the respects in which that's
true is exactly what you've said.
I think there are others too.
But the big, big,
big difference as Professor Dawkins and
when we finished our conversation at the
y, he and his wife, the actress Lala Ward,
kind of gave her the final
dramatic flourish. They did
a reading from his book,
a devil's chaplain,
but he insists that our great advantage
as a species is we finally have the
brainpower to make our
own future for ourselves.
For Good Darwinian reasons.
Evolution gave us a brain whose size
increased to the point where it became
capable of understanding its
own provenance of deploring,
the moral implications, and
to fighting against them.
The Shark may out swim you the Cheetah
out run you the swift out fly you the
kappa, not climb you the elephant
out power you, the redwoods,
and speaking about gifts.
When it comes to
internalizing the very cosmos,
we turn to the Alfred p Sloan Foundation
and to the National Science Foundation
and of course to the corporation
for public broadcasting.
I'm Robert Krulwich. Chad, we'll
be back with the very soon.
I'm thinking you better
be so long. For now.